hey hey what's up everybody thanks for
tuning into a live episode of let to be
talk brought to you right here from the
great pop-up studio ATC pop-up studio in
Phoenix today we are in Phoenix Arizona
and the festival is presented to you by
Bud Light cityscape and Tito's handmade
vodka right here we're alive on the
street there's absolutely zero fans here
which it oh no sorry sorry two fans we
got two people well meanwhile we are the
left to be talking I always say I'm the
stepchild of ATC out here over five and
a half years podcasting 300 and I don't
know 87 episodes and meanwhile
everyone's over it for Christ airs
across the street I'm over here with
Noah that's how my career is it's like
it's going to be great for you wait till
you get out there yeah all right it's
about it right here anyway I don't care
actually because it's I love doing the
show and I I like I said five year over
five years I've been doing this podcast
and it just went by and I didn't even
have like some 5-year anniversary but I
wrote down some notes on that 911
reviews which is pretty damn amazing
I've been trying to get to a thousand
but in the last few weeks the reviews
have been incredible people stacking
them up and don't forget to subscribe
and keep that going I have a something I
want you guys to do if you are a
longtime listener I get a lot of people
that say you shouldn't have such and
such on the show or whatever and I've
already had that person on so I think a
cool thing to do would to be all this
week as you listen to this episode what
you should do is tweet a link to your
favorite episode you know like say you
liked one with Nikki Sixx go hey my
favorite let there be talk is Nikki Sixx
episode and tweet it so other people
could find it
and as I thought about that I went
through some of my favorite episodes
and I said look back and let the be
talking and the reason I was looking
back was I was pretty damn happy to be
part of this network when I first was
asked to do it years ago I think there
was only about seven podcast on ATC and
it was like Bill burr
it was Ari Shaffir Tom Segura Bert
Kreischer al Madrigal had one on there
the minivan podcast I think it was
called minivan dads or something Doug
Stanhope and then when I was asked to be
part of the network I was pretty pretty
blown away and proud so I looked back a
little bit at some of my favorite
episodes
I look back Jerry Cantrell I was on tour
with Jerry Cantrell and Alice in Chains
last year got to do a podcast with him
that was a dream guest which was amazing
Dave manna Kenny from Y&T a lot of
people think that's the all-time best
episode on let to be talk and I gotta
say as I look at that episode I think it
was right around when I probably had
diabetes at first and didn't realize it
because as I did that episode which was
three hours I had to go across the
street and do a show at the San Jose
improv and on the the adrenaline I think
of interviewing one of your idols and
the lack of food and stuff man I felt
right after that thing and I just
kind of was I looked back at that now go
wow I think that was sick then but that
was an amazing episode of course Jerry
Kasauli from Devo I did two parts with
him and his Devo being one of my
favorite bands of all time that was
monumental to me Alison Mosshart Alison
Mosshart from The Kills in the dead
weather she does not do interviews and
to have her on let her be talk was next
level and we have become very good
friends and of course the ultimate was a
few weeks ago Nikki Sixx from Motley
Crue which blew the
the numbers right out of the right out
of the park and a couple days
ago because of that podcast I got to
host Nikki Sixx's book signing live book
signing that was worldwide and that
was insane so that's some of my great
podcast guests then I looked back on of
course I loved all the episodes I think
about the handmade episodes and and I
really loved the handmade episodes I'm
proud of those and I want to try to get
a TV show with that going on but to have
people on that make stuff and work
outside the box in this in this world is
incredible if it's art or you know
you're an architect or you build
choppers or make clothes or whatever I
love those kind of people and I think
back to one of my favorite handmaids
which was Bogor ii from LA watch works
and we talked Rolex
Kevin Christy and I with him we're huge
watch fans and I've you know these
episodes are not always the biggest but
to me those seemed to be the best
because people learn from them
and I used to love this show growing up
in the Bay Area called Bay Area
backroads where the guy would go to
weird spots all over the Bay Area and
you would learn about people so I
love that
and speaking of watches yesterday the
Paul Newman legendary Paul Newman
Daytona sold for seventeen million seven
hundred dollars and that is a world
record for a wristwatch wrist watch
wrist watch and the insane the
insaneness of that watch I believe it
was probably around it was bought in
1968 I don't know the exact price but it
was probably bought new for about nine
hundred dollars so can you imagine
buying something in 1968 and then
selling it today for seventeen million
seven hundred thousand dollars that's
unbelievable to me and the thing is I
love Rolex is and I love the
Daytona and the Daytona is always known
as the Paul Newman watch because it was
the one that his lady bought him and he
started wearing it during racing and you
know when I when a watches nicknamed
after you that's the iconic watch so
that particular watch he gave to a guy
that was dating his daughter I want to
get this right here's how the story goes
which is really great story and I'll
tweet it up later I'm sure you guys are
seeing all the clickbait on it all over
the internet right now of Paul Newman
Rolex sells for seventeen seven and then
you start digging around like I think my
grandpa has a Rolex and you think you're
rich you gotta wait a few minutes here
and look at it let's see here let me get
the rundown here it is Joanne Woodward
purchased the Rolex watch in 1968 a
Tiffany and company in New York during
the same period that Newman was
embarking on his racing career mindful
of her husband's new interest she had
the back of the watch engraved with
driving me carefully
sorry drive carefully me that derived me
carefully that's pretty thick and drive
carefully
me the following year the couple
appeared in the film winning together
where Newman played a racing driver
competing Indy 500 the film was inspired
the auctions title winning icons which
where the watch was auctioned off at
Philips in New York yesterday over the
years the Rolex Paul Newman Daytona has
become known as taken on a mythical
proportion and here's how it went down
right here let's see where is that story
I gotta find that actually III don't
know wait here I think it's at the top
of the story here's how the guy that
sold it got it he this is if I wasn't
doing alive this is where I would be
pausing and trying to get my
together
[Laughter]
let's see here here it is in 1984 watch
owner James Cox was given the watch by
Paul Newman Newman was dating or sorry
Paul Cox was dating Newman's daughter
Coxon Newman haven't been a couple since
93 but they both went to the auction
together they auction it off and part of
the money's going toward a bunch of
stuff some causes that Paul Newman would
have loved anyway another that I got all
sidetracked but it's pretty insane for a
watch to sell for 17 million that's not
gold it doesn't have diamonds it it's
just a stainless steel watch that was
you know in the 80s nobody wanted nobody
cared about those watches they thought
they were ugly anyway so back to my
point is I love the handmade episodes
and I'm pretty proud of them as far as
some upcoming dream guests everybody
always asked here your dream guest is
and I have many but since I booked the
guests myself they're really hard to get
and almost impossible it has to be like
an almost fluke that it happens like I'm
here in Phoenix I would have loved to
have Alice Cooper he lives here but he's
on tour in Europe one of my dream guess
would be Rob Halford from Judas Priest
I hit him at Instagram which is
hilarious like hey buddy he doesn't even
know me maybe you could stop down at the
pop-up podcast where no one's at and do
my podcast I know you're not busy yeah
anyway he would have been great and then
I hit up Dave Elson which was going to
do it from Megadeth but he flew to South
America today to play with Megadeth so I
thought you know those are some amazing
Phoenix guests and the way this show
usually works is eventually they all
become guests on here and they seem to
happen right in time when I don't have a
guest some magic will happen one of my
biggest dream guests I saw two nights
ago I went to see the yeah yeah
yes at the Fonda they have not played
for four years as a band and many times
over the years doing this podcast people
say hey who's your your greatest
frontman front persons who do you love
and who do you think was the greatest
you ever seen and I always say you know
one of them being Bon Scott of course
another one of the greatest front
persons people of all time would be to
me Robert Plant
but then when I really look into it I
think about Zack de la Rocha from Rage
Against the Machine one of the most
dangerous ever Axl Rose of course is in
there I always love danger
I love authenticity and and and all that
and this woman Kara know is definitely
in the top five six seven of greatest
front people of all time that I've ever
seen front of band and people are like
Kara no and I laugh because I think
about if your end up matey Gaga that's
cool I always say promote what's great
not what you hate but I laugh when
people talk about like Lady Gaga or any
of these you know female pop stars and
they try to they try to say that they're
artists they're amazing
no one comes close to Kara no and as I
watched her again at 38 years old a
couple nights ago which is not old but
in a rock and roll world sometimes
people start to mellow out or they
change and as I watched her once again
it was just like the first time I ever
saw her live she absolutely blew my
mind
and the crowd hats off to the Fonda
crowd that was there in LA cuz LA crowds
are usually pretty sedate they were
going ballistic and you could tell the
world missed the yeah yes and they've
got a box set out right now and they
reissued their
their record the fever record on vinyl
180 milligrams an incredible box set so
Karen L which by the way I ran into her
manager Dave Becky who also manages bill
burr and sometimes I'm just blunt right
to people and I was like look Becky I've
got to have her on it he was like yeah
alright yeah but Karen oh one day I hope
to have her on because she is absolutely
incredible
so that is hopefully a guest coming up
one day let's get into it here so the
episode I've been wanting to talk about
Tom Petty since he passed away and it
was a really rough topic for me to talk
about because I absolutely worshipped
Tom Petty and of course we lost him
just a few weeks ago which is insane you
know to think about I saw the last show
ever now which I can't even believe I'm
never gonna see Tom Petty again I think
he was 66 years old and that's a psalm
at the Hollywood Bowl I had no idea that
that was going to be the last time I
ever saw and and you know as much as
Prince really affected me and Bowie
petty to me I had opened for petty
playing music I had seen petty zillions
of times and he just seemed like one of
my friends like you know I just thought
he'd be around forever and even though I
didn't know him he's one of those guys
that just felt like a an uncle or
something he's always there he's always
on the radio he's always in my life and
I think a lot of people just just
figured petty would be around forever he
has a zillion hits the first time I ever
saw Tom Petty was on into the great wide
open tour they had a giant tree on the
stage
many Kravitz opened on the lenten of
rule
tor and it was it was just insane and
from that on that that Aaron I
absolutely fell in love with Tom Petty
you know Tom Petty a lot of people of
course know the hits Tom Petty's a lot
like the cars Tom Petty could play an
entire show of only hits and you would
just be like I can't believe there's no
piss track so I always call that when
you go to a concert and you're like oh
good here's a song I can go take a piss
- Tom Petty has no piss tracks which is
incredible but what I thought would be
cool is to go through the records today
and celebrate the songs the deep tracks
that nobody ever talks about which is
incredible because of course Tom Petty
has all these hits but he also has these
deep tracks that any other band if any
other band had one of these songs it
would be their number one song
and they'd be playing county fairs their
whole life on one song you know which by
the way on the way out here to Phoenix I
saw a billboard for Uncle Kracker Uncle
Kracker was playing some casino and I
was like Uncle Kracker I mean I couldn't
pick him out of a two-man lineup you
know to me Uncle Kracker was a DJ in for
Kid Rock and I think he had won like
semi I'm not even gonna call it a hit
I'm not ripping on him or anything but
it was hilarious to think that a guy
like Uncle Kracker was out still working
and then I thought if he had one of
these Tom Petty deep tracks he would
probably be doing even better you know
he'd be beat you'd be able to do like
every Festival on the planet with one
song so I thought it'd be cool to
celebrate some Tom Petty deep tracks and
a lot of people a lot of people are
gonna dig this that don't know Tom Petty
other than the standard song so we'll
get into the first record right now
which is the first Tom Petty record came
out in 1976 and it really was the
see how old was I was 10 years old I was
born in 66 I'm old as I'm 51 but it
came out in 76 and I absolutely remember
my mom had this piece-of-shit Volkswagen
bug and had a great AM radio and this
track breakdown came on and I think that
was really where I fell in love with the
I would call that a rock ballad it's not
your standard 80s you know Whitesnake is
this love that kind of ballad but it's a
it's an actual you know it's got a
ballad feel to it and that's when I
first find out about Tom Petty and I go
out and I get that record I believe
about not for like two years because my
first record is Partridge Family I think
I love you that's the first piece of
vinyl I owned and then it was Don
McLean's bye bye miss American Pie has
that clear my throat fur was telling me
something funny why we're on the road
this guy was talking to us and he didn't
clear his throat and BER was like I
hate guys that don't clear their
throat clear your throat man you
walked away all heated come on just
drink some water or cough Scolari's you
know when you got that and you don't
want to be rude like when I'm doing
morning radio I don't want to be rude
and be like coughing on it so you just
ride it out so things that birds say to
me stick with me I'm like I better come
I throw it around BRR I don't want him
to be like this guy anyway so
Don McLean bye bye Miss America pie and
then kiss rock and roll over so those
are the three records but then I get
heavily into Tom Petty which is crazy
and I think that's the early juxtapose
of mymusictaste if you go from like
Partridge Family I'd still listen to
that right now
kiss Tom Petty you know and then later
on getting into some R&B of like Earth
Wind and Fire
so anyway the first record as
breakdown an American girl everybody
knows those tunes everybody there their
Americana their apple pie of rock and
roll everybody worships them but if you
don't know this song and I'm going to
play a little bit snippets of each song
just to give you a little taste this rec
this song right here fooled again was on
a track number seven check it out
you
[Music]
[Applause]
what a great song absolutely love that
track that's on the first record so you
know get out there and get all your deep
Tom Petty tracks man you know you're
gonna be blown away it'll be like having
a new Tom Petty record you know what I'm
saying you'll be like oh my God look at
all this gold right here so that that's
off the 76 first record which by the way
how about your first record you got
breakdown an American girl you like yeah
I got a couple tunes here and here we
are in 2017 it's played every day of our
lives on classic rock radio just
unbelievable the second record coming
out which a lot of people don't even
know about the second record which is
pretty funny it came out in 78 it goes
down to those things where I always ask
people why did you stop listening to a
band and I've sent it over and over how
come you don't listen to Kings of Leon
anymore if you love them and they're
like I don't know do they got a new
record and you're like are you out of
your mind
that if you look at a band like Tom
Petty that has breakdown an American
girl why wouldn't you borrow this the
next record right away I mean to me I'm
like I can't wait for their new record
I'm a music junkie I want to hear what
they got so the next record comes out in
78 you're gonna get it and everybody
knows the hits you know don't do me like
that refugee here comes my girl which
which by the way how great is that line
I think it's one of the greatest lines
ever you think you're gonna take her
away with your money in your cocaine
that that is a genius line right there
that that record came out in 78 but a
lot of people don't know about this song
on the record which is incredible and I
and I also want to give heads up to
their drummer Stan Lynch who later on
left and you can watch that Tom Petty
documentary it's four hours on Netflix
and I truly believe and I've said it
over and over the key to a great
and if there are a killer band and
they're amazing always around they've
got a great drummer without a great
drummer your band just is just mediocre
and probably isn't gonna be one of the
greats
and stan Lynch is one of the all-time
greatest swing drummers he's got groove
and feel he's a lot like Adler in Guns
and Roses once you get a different
drummer yeah they're great drummers
technically but the feel is gone and I
and I love Tom Petty and of course later
on they played without Stan Lynch but in
the back of my head I was always like
wow I wish Stan Lynch was still here
playing these grooves you know and and
it's funny I was talking about a couple
days ago I don't know what the hell Stan
Lynch is doing right now and you just
don't hear about him but man that guy
was drum gold it's a lot like you know
when you get into the the whole thing
with the police people don't like each
other in bands but man
you gotta have that feel anyway let's
get into the net magnetic my next
favorite song
deep track which is on that record the
second record you're gonna get it you
gotta get it and here it is the song is
called shadow of a doubt and I think you
guys will enjoy this and here you go
let's see yeah I'm just doing all this
on the fly so usually at home I would
add these songs later I've actually had
to kind of get my together where is
this track I could oh oh you know what I
got the wrong track on here is this wait
what's my shadow of doubt look oh that's
in the third record sorry I'm out of my
mind
Restless is the one Restless right here
here we go here it is right here
[Music]
it is right there and since we are doing
this live I kind of up a little
bit on my notes because I'm the notes
are just all crammed together like a
crazy man
anyway that's on the second record but
then I mentioned tracks from damn the
torpedoes people out there which is
great cuz people hey dude you're all
wrong there dude you you don't
know what you're talking about
I was mentioning tunes off damn the
torpedoes and then played a deep track
off you're gonna get get it which the
you know which is funny cuz listen to
your heart is the track with the cocaine
America course you know and that song
was off the second record the third
record damn the torpedoes is what I was
talking about don't do me like that
refugee here comes my girl and of course
that is the absolute record that blows
the doors open for Tom Petty smash hit
songs the record comes out in 1979 it is
just a classic everything about Tom
Petty is on this record if you look at
the cover
he's got the Rickenbacker and I always
thought as a kid it was called down the
torpedoes but it's Tim the torpedoes of
course it's a 36 minute record of
smashing tunes and there's a deep track
on this record that I just think is
phenomenal and and not very many people
talk about it and I'll play it for it's
called shadow of a doubt here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
that song is so smokin man killer
grilled us those bongos you got to love
those songs Oh see there man
[Music]
[Applause]
so smoking management and the great
thing about that song is it's got all
the Tom babe Tom Petty flavor you know
that's the sound of the Heartbreakers
right there which the band is so
underrated so underrated Benmont Tench
on the b3 organ come on man that guy
Mike Campbell Mike Campbell is one of
the greatest secret weapons in rock and
roll ever and a lot of people don't know
but he played the slide on 6th avenue
heartache on The Wallflowers track and
that is one of the big hooks on the song
you know with songwriting there's so
much to it there's hooks you got the
course it's hooky they sticks in your
head you've got the you got the thematic
lead that's hooky and then you have some
lyrics that are hooky and when you have
that thematic lead Mike Campbell many
many many times over and over and over
hitting home runs with the perfect
perfect you know perfect lead or just
some kind of tasty thing in there which
by the way one of the best things about
seeing Tom Petty live if you're a guitar
freak like myself these guys would go
out with about 20 guitars each you know
most rock stars would it play one guitar
maybe two their entire life like Jimmy
Page Les Paul there it is the flame top
Clapton a black strat you know Blackie
Angus Young SG everybody would have like
one or two guitars but when you go see
petty they're gonna have an incredible
amp collection which I always would look
at and then they're gonna have an
incredible guitar collection so not only
you're getting great songs and a great
concert but then if you're a super gear
freak nerd like me you start going like
oh look at that Fiesta red strat
and they both have them oh look at that
Firebird one with one pickup they both
have them they'd come out and both play
the same guitars Rickenbacker's
incredible acoustics
insane so that's one of the fun things
Patti came out with a record a lot of
people don't know a lot of these records
a lot of people know the first record
then they know damn the torpedoes but
they don't know stuff like you're gonna
get it or hard promises and petty came
out with a record called hard promises
and it had two monster hits on it great
songs the waiting and woman in love but
a lot of people don't know this track
which I feel could have been a song on
the Eagles long run record it really has
the Eagles long run vibe to it and
you'll understand when I play it for you
the hard promises record came out in
1981 and this song is called the night
watchman
[Music]
[Applause]
what an incredible song right there Matt
sounds like something off the long run
you know like them shoes you know denna
that stuff was great and this hard
promises record also you know of course
you know about the big hit that Tom
Petty and Stevie Nicks did on her record
and if you've watched that Defiant ones
on HBO which by the way is one of the
greatest documentaries I've ever seen
with dr. Dre and Jimmy Iovine and Jimmy
Iovine is one of the genius producers
behind Tom Petty and an absolute master
if you watch that you'll see the whole
dynamics between Tom Petty and Stevie
Nicks and learn a lot of crazy secrets
about that but on this record there was
a beautiful beautiful ballad that they
did together called The Insider and it's
absolutely fantastic
[Music]
anyway check that record out it's so
good and you know it's just loaded with
loaded with great deep tracks killer
album cover I love that let's get into
this one here in 82 petty came out with
a record long after dark and it's got
him on the cover with a Tele which
that's the Tom Petty for me I feel Tom
Petty when he puts on a Telecaster
that's Tom Petty to me made me love the
Telecaster him and Bruce Springsteen I
used to hate the Telecaster growing up I
was like that guitar is not rock that
thing's dumb you know I just do it's
just I was just an idiot I was like
that's country-western that's not rock
and roll and then I was so dumb you know
because look Bruce is the king of rock
and roll and so is Petty and they both
play Telly's and later on that tell me
that Petty played on the wildflowers
records some dude made it for my talked
about it a few times it's my favorite
tele ever made and it made me want to
get a telly and I've been at Le freak
every sense and I think it's the
greatest guitar ever made for a
singer-songwriter kind of Americana
rocker if you're gonna strum a guitar
you're not like a lead demon that guitar
the Telecaster is the one this has long
after dark as a picture of them on the
cover with the great Telecaster it looks
like a Telecaster custom which is one of
my favorites with the binding and
everything on it I love telling customs
this record long after dark had the
great hit you got lucky you got lucky
baby and change your heart would
disagree when he had a change but you
know nobody really knows about that song
change their heart too much but the
really cool deep track on this is
straight into darkness and another great
dark dark deep track here it is straight
at darkness
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody is the king of the course the
guy's the greatest course and great
great lyrics it's so hard to write
lyrics you know everything's been set
everything has been since she left me I
love her I don't love her I'm drunk I
got a car I go fast let's let's shoot
out the night whatever everything has
been saying about everything it's like
comedy when you think about writing
jokes everybody has said it already so
what is your take on it what is your
take on love was your take on you know
traveling what is your take on being
poor what is your take on being rich
whatever you need to have your your your
take be original on it and that's what
people say when it comes to comedians of
having your own voice and same with
writing and lyrics
everything has been said next up the
record this is an interesting thing in
1985 Tom Petty put out a record called
southern accents and I remember
specifically Jakob Dylan who I respect
and I think it's one of the greatest
songwriters Witchita Bruce Springsteen
recently named Jakob Dylan one of the
top ten great songwriters in his mind
that's Bruce Springsteen saying that and
I always say the magnitude of having Bob
Dylan as your your dad you know try try
and erase that shadow it's
absolutely impossible you know how many
people have famous dads and as soon as
they're in it people are like see you
later
you know and and try to do that
and then he does it and then has
incredible hit records a long-running
career and amazing songwriter my point
is I remember talking one night with
Jacob about Tom Petty which many times
we talked about Tom and I said what's
your favorite song and he's like oh man
he it was so funny because I remember
him telling me in this right away
he was like southern accents the actual
song southern accents so the hit on the
record is what is it don't come around
here no more course massive hit but
southern accents and as I went back and
listened to that after Jacob told me
that I was like this is a great song
[Music]
that's a beautiful song man right there
southern accents got an amazing now we
cover all of Petty's covers our great
southern accents that's a track I didn't
really know about because when we start
getting into petty deep in the 80s you
know he's putting out records and they
kind of be they're kind of going by
especially this next record which me I'm
a giant Tom Petty fan and this record to
me is the strangest Tom Petty record
that he ever put out it was in 1980 87
called let me up I've had enough
it had the song on a jam and me you know
everybody knows that one petty would
open a lot of shows with it you jam in
me it was so great man it's just a great
rock'n roller and great lyric you're
jamming me but it's a really weird
record it's a strange-looking cover it
looks 80s it's kind of tearaway they are
they call it tearaway and I love the
editors notes let me I've had enough is
a return to the tight hard rock classic
that established Tom Petty and I was
reading this and I was like this this
doesn't sound like petty to me much
where it kind of sounds more like the
times at the times we had dire straits
was big out there you know and and this
kind of sound you'll hear it because
this song right here on the record which
is a great track it kind of as a Dylan
meets dire straits vibe to it and it's
called my life your world and check it
out man totally totally crazy sound him
oh I that up that was a bad move
that's what happens when you're going
live hold on we got to get that again
because I know I don't want to I don't
want to mess that up see I'm trying to
I'm trying to cue up the songs as I'm
doing it which is totally something I
wouldn't do I would usually just drop
the tunes in and this kind of podcast
would take me about seven hours
to do I have no producer I have no
assistants or anything so I'd be sitting
home on a Sunday dropping these tunes in
losing my mind but let's get
back in
[Music]
wait for it which by the way that was a
weird intro it's like a weird country
intro into this
kind of dire straits
also one headlight
[Music]
I'm willing to bet like 99% of people
out there have not heard that Tom Petty
song and it's just like what a cool
flavor man it's definitely different
sounding for Tom Petty and really
smoking you know and you got to look at
that error right there that's probably
in most people eyes they're like yeah
you know Tom Petty
he might be done now you know a lot of
times I think the industry would think
you know Tom Petty he you know he had
those great seventies hits and you know
he's probably done and and in the
business in the business people are like
he's getting a little long in the tooth
you know you're in the biz let's say
that's nineteen what is that what year
is that record 87 so he had been in the
biz
let's see 76 to 87 that's a long career
right there already in rock and roll so
people are thinking maybe he's done that
record didn't have a monster hit and
then he slips off and does his first
solo record which absolutely
murders full moon fever you are not even
ready for how big this record comes out
full moon fever 1989 look at the hits on
it free fallin I won't back down
[Music]
running down a dream this thing is
loaded of course he had Johnny Depp in
his video cruisin around and a Harley
absolutely murdering it and you know
just full full of hits you know
but a lot of people don't know this song
on full moon fever because it was so hit
hit and loaded that people probably just
listen to the hits I mean look at all
those hits on it but this song love is
the long road is incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
she chose
[Music]
[Applause]
what a great great great song right
there and just once again any other band
it would be their best song ever
it's just track number five or whatever
on a petty record you know just
unbelievable this guy just smoking and
then he follows it up with one of the
greatest Heartbreakers records into the
great wide open 1991 which has crazy
hits on it too
you know into the great wine of course
learning to fly an incredible incredible
song and this is when I see petty so 91
you know I'm thinking I had to see petty
before this my brain is pretty shot
because I can't imagine that I didn't
see petty before 91 you know but I do
think I remember this tour so vividly it
was that Oakland Coliseum and it was one
of those ones where I went last minute
and then thank God I saw it and and also
like I said Lenny Kravitz open the tour
on let love rules and Kravitz was
crushing it with that you know that
record is fantastic with all that
Freedom Train and let love rule and mr.
cab driver all those songs so
that's just a song Smith night there you
go see Tom Petty and Lenny Kravitz
together
you're just an overdose of incredible
songwriting but of course that record
had learning to fly on it and into the
great wide open massive massive hits but
the song I love is out in the cold man
this thing is great not to be confused
with
[Music]
[Applause]
right there there it is out in the cold
I feel like a radio DJ right now there
it is right there k 95 105 we got
traffic out there and Phoenix is hot as
out there stay off the highway at
Tom Petty he'll be here coming soon
right there they just radio boy
all right yeah all right most people and
I would say most monster Tom Petty fans
monster Tom Petty fans are all going to
say this next record was the one that
that they probably play every day of
their life if they get up to want to
hear some Tom Petty think I want to hear
some Tom Petty they're gonna put this
record on in 1994 Tom Petty worked with
Rick Rubin and they went to Sound City
and they trapped what could be one of
the greatest records ever to come out of
an American songwriter they did a saw a
record called wild flowers which I
didn't know until about a year ago was
actually going to be a double record now
what I understand and I read this
somewhere and then I've been trying to
find it again but if you listen to the
LA Times last interview with Tom Petty
which was done two days after the last
show ever at Hollywood Bowl so September
27th or so LA Times went out and
interviewed Tom Petty for about an hour
and he had planned to do some
wildflowers shows wildflowers were
supposed to be a double album which I
never knew and the record company which
Tom Petty had fought all his life he
always fought with record companies over
album prices over songs over royalties
this guy was a soldier he does
not get enough credit for changing a lot
of stuff for other artists and I read
even recently I read that he was pretty
bummed when his label wanted to raise
the record once he was popular they
wanted to raise his price of his record
a dollar more than anybody else's and
like you you're not doing that and
he said he was really surprised that
other artists didn't back him up on this
he was like wow it's just out there by
myself a lot like Laura Zorich when he
was bad on Napster you know and now
everybody's like cool Mars looks like he
was right you know but you know you're
out there and you believe in something
and then you don't have any backup from
your other peers it's always insane to
me because you know it's all about the
artist and he's like hey man we're
ripping off fans here let's say no to
all the other people in there like I
don't want to I don't want to
cause any waves I just want to play rock
and roll dude why are you always so
edgy yeah and I love that about
Tom Mann he's an absolute
soldier so he puts out wild flowers it's
not a double record and I heard that
they're going to do a box set that's
going to have the original wildflowers
record and then the second record
together the combination of Rick Rubin
and Tom Petty was it was monumental it
was monumental because Tom was at a part
in his career where his records were
kind of big big hits big sounding a lot
like elo I'm not like you know that that
will Barry's thing harmonies all kinds
of sonic bigness which can also be a
curse later which it never was with
petty but you can put a record on you go
oh my god this records so 80s listen to
those reverbs and those gates and that
you know the vocal Reuben was
wise and said let's strip it back down
let's hear the songs for what they are
the record is an absolute masterpiece
Tom's records all have hits and they
have songs that I love on them but this
record is 100% masterpiece all the way
through and I can't even
imagine what the outtakes are going to
be like they're not outtakes they were
just songs from the second record they
didn't come out but I really want to
hear this second session which is and
this is one of the big travesties of Tom
Petty passing away we're never gonna get
to see him play these double record from
top to bottom but I did see this tour a
million times and it was when I'd become
full-blown Tom Petty fanatic and I mean
like it's it's right at the time let's
see here 94 I learned to play guitar
around 90 I would say 96 and this is one
of the reasons probably because I'm like
well I really I really need to write my
own songs before I just wrote lyrics and
melodies but I was a slave if I didn't
have a guitar player or keyboard player
around and I realized holy I want
to be able to go out and play every day
of my life if I want to like a comedian
right now I full freedom I don't need
any other person but me to do comedy and
with rock and roll if you don't play an
instrument let's say Pete Townsend and
Roger Daltrey Roger Daltrey without Pete
Townsend is just a great great singer
but he didn't write music and he didn't
write lyrics but that combination worked
great but for Roger Daltrey just to
break off solo never could do it so this
record it did all kinds of things to me
it made me love worship vintage
equipment amplifiers and guitars it made
me love photography because the cover is
beautiful with these photos it made me
love Rick Rubin which I already did love
of course for years but it was great to
see Rick Rubin start to break off into
some Americana of course early on he's
known for Slayer
Run DMC you know doing those mashups and
and then of course masters of reality
all that stuff anyway
petty puts this rock
it out and it just murders
there's a song on it that are always
worshipped and on the last show on
September 25th I believe it was when I
saw Tom Petty he played this song he did
four songs from the wildflowers which
made everybody in the audience go loony
that's how much people love this record
then he played this song and I was just
like I just got goosebumps every time I
hear this
[Applause]
[Music]
waiting
it's a smoker smoker song right there
and of course wildflowers if you're a
part-time Tom Petty fan and you do not
own this record immediately run out and
buy it immediately you know it's just a
masterpiece and it is definitely in 99%
of Tom Petty's fans the deep deep fans
it's their favorite record of all time
right after that he put out a weird
record called she's the one songs and
music from the motion picture which is a
throw away Jennifer Aniston film in 96
you know just some junk or film and it
has Tom Petty happened to do the whole
soundtrack and Tom Petty I think some of
these wildflowers tracks it didn't make
it on there I believe are tracks from
this session which I've read and I know
it is because of the sound of it and I
think it was extra tracks that he had so
if it's these songs and there's even
more songs from the wildflowers sessions
it's just insane because these songs are
great a lot of people don't know this
record it's really really bizarre record
he covers Beck which is one of
my favorite Beck songs but he covers one
of my favorite songwriters ever Lucinda
Williams changed the locks which is such
a great nod to her which I think
probably boosted her bank account big
time because she is a complete
you know she's like she's one of the
all-time best and most people don't know
who she is and I've talked about car
wheels on a gravel road a million times
on this podcast as being one of the
greatest records ever made and this
songs on there Tom Petty covered it
changed the locks but there's a song on
this record that I believe is absolutely
stunning and it's called angel
dream number four and here it is
[Music]
I dreamed you I saw your face cut my
when drifting through space
[Music]
that's all danger
so my thing
[Music]
that's the kind of Tom Petty song that
just grabs me every time right there I'm
a sucker for that kind of just the
instrument Tom Petty right there and
every time I pick up a guitar and strum
it I try to write something like that
just like oh what a tune it's not gonna
get you rich and it's not going to be
some number one hit but it's all about
what he's talking about
yeah in this in this lyric you know and
it's just beautiful and it catches you
right away and I love that and that's a
weird record and I really recommend it
man because I think it's very underrated
very underrated record so yeah anyway
get into it I'm gonna do two more
records and then I got to get out of
here but I really doing this is kind of
therapeutic for me because I've still
pretty blown away that he's gone
sixty-six years old I can't tell you
enough go out and live your life and
don't sit on the couch and just
rot away you know you're here go do
something because you don't know when
you're going to be gone and for Tom
Petty to be gone I've seriously thought
that he was gonna be like Dylan Dylan is
I believe the last will bury alive oh no
Jeff Lynn who worked on it but you know
who thought that Dylan was gonna do you
know outlive them all you know and
Dylan's out there just playing every day
of his life and Willie Nelson's still
out there plane I really thought that
Tom Petty would be like Willie Nelson or
or Dylan and just be out there forever I
I figured Tom Petty would outlive me man
I mean that's just kind of how life
would go it would go okay it's
summertime gonna go see petty you know
there's things I remember Tom papa used
to have this great joke he's like why
does people want why do people want to
live forever it's just the same
every year it's like New Year's
Eve Superbowl fourth-of-july he did that
joke years ago and it's stuck in my head
I absolutely loved it and that's kind of
life is he's be like New Year's Eve
Superbowl fourth of July Tom Petty
concert that's how I figure life is
gonna go Tom Petty an interesting thing
I did not know about him and I had I had
okay on the there's a record called echo
which he does next in 1999 which I think
is one of the darkest greatest Tom Petty
records ever wrote and if you watch the
documentary or you read about Tom Petty
he's going through a bad divorce and he
gets hooked on heroin like that and it's
like you ever meet a guy like 40 they
start smoking you're like what the
are you doing dude you're 40 you you you
made it you don't just start smoking Tom
Petty yeah I forget what age it is he
just goes yeah this year I'm gonna try
heroin
it just becomes a full-blown heroin
addict which at the time this is right
around when I start I opened for Tom
Petty and I thought it was the last DJ
record but I think it's echo and I could
ask my bass player cuz his brains a
little better he did less cocaine I
believe but Tom Petty had a bass player
because Ron the original bass player
left the band and they got a bass player
named Howie Epstein who to me is one of
the greatest greatest bass players and
background singers ever to be in the
rock and roll game and he is in the
Heartbreakers for years and he did all
the incredible harmony vocals and he
just had this really weird vibe doing he
had a crazy hairdo and he was just
really interesting you know and him and
Patti are just full-on doing heroin
which is just crazy and and Howie at the
time me and my bass player Joey we would
go see Patti and we would like holy
how he's about to
I can nod off on the mic he was just
doze off and and he was just out of it
and he's so out of it that he doesn't
even make the photoshoot for the echo
record so if you look at it it's the
whole Heartbreakers band but no Howie he
doesn't make the photoshoot for a major
major record release
I mean how you like to me I was mad
at band members when they didn't make it
to rehearsal like I can't make it
tonight I want to watch friends with my
girlfriend but to not make an a photo
shoot for the album cover I would be
steaming I don't care how good
you are I'd be like you're gone
so he doesn't make it
but this echo record is very dark and
it's an incredible incredible record the
the hit on it semi hit it's not like a
big American girl hit but the single
they released was free girl now which
was an interesting song but the song
that I loved on it and I think you'll
dig it too was this one here counting on
you
[Music]
[Applause]
right there great great great song they
also had another song on this record
that almost sounds like Nirvana which
would be let's see right you know check
out this tune right here it's kind of
Nirvana sound and right here where is it
right here
I don't want to fight listen to this
[Music]
[Applause]
Yeah right there that's a divorce record
man they call it some colleges blood on
the track she's killing blood on the
tracks had to divorce song where did
that song titles you're a free girl now
swinging accused of love I don't want to
fight this one's for me all all cut
Rhino skin Oh Rhino skins cool check it
real quick I forgot about this one
what great tune
[Music]
you need Rhino skin elephant balls
anyway great great record and we can go
on and on I'm running out of time here
and before I I wind this down I would do
want to bring a guest up but anyway
that's some of my suggestions for some
of the greatest Tom Petty deep tracks
and really getting into one of the most
incredible songwriters of all time and
one of the greatest performers and an
absolute soldier never sold out as
people always say you know what I mean
and a treasure man a treasure a
hall-of-famer a Wilbury
he toured with Dylan Dylan in the
Heartbreakers this guy did it all his
dreams came true it was all hard
work and it was non-stop songwriting and
he'd never ever select all his live
shows were incredible including the 20
nights I saw him at the Fillmore in San
Francisco everything about Tom Petty to
me is absolutely home run and the
high-water mark of a career and a human
I love Tom Petty and like I said it felt
great to do this episode today it was
really it was really heartbreaking to
find out that he died and I still still
cannot believe he's gone and and and
I'll always shout him out on Instagram
and Twitter just to constantly keep that
that thought out there because you know
he's not coming back and I do I do look
hope look forward to the Heartbreakers
doing something I think one of the
greatest things would be a lot of people
think what do you think the
Heartbreakers is gonna do yeah cuz
they're the greatest players in the game
and they're still there what would be
really cool is if Springsteen went out
with the Heartbreakers and did a
Heartbreakers tour a full tribute to Tom
Petty I think that would be insane
springsteen out there I thank you
everybody that digs deep into into the
catalogues of that that great man's
music and and thank you for all your
support
ATC all things comedy absolutely amazing
Network and over the years of doing
stand-up and this podcast I've met some
great people
I'll bring up my guest right now Greg
Reilly I've talked about him many times
el cajon Harley of course early on I met
Greg and San Diego at the Gesta moja
Comedy Store I can't really remember how
are you buddy
man good where did we meet Tommy Cole I
think for some time oh there you go
listen to you and it's amazing the great
thing about comedy is and I look around
in this room Aaron it was on that on the
dials on this show all the people I've
met over the years
Paul virzi just walked in Eleanor
Kerrigan walked by everybody on this
festival I think about eight years ago I
didn't know any people and now I have
all these great friends you know bill
burr el mágico
everybody stand hope Bert Kreischer
everyone on this network are my friends
and also people like you that I met and
we've become really tight
we've traveled the work not the world
but we traveled around we've seen rock
and roll together and we've we've we got
a partnership where you sponsor the
podcast El Cajon Harley which is insane
we're about to go ride some 2018
Harley's right now after this we're
gonna go out into the desert and see
what these new bikes are all about
pretty fired up about that hell yeah
it's the hottest bike out there for
Harley 2008 Fat Bob the new motor you're
gonna be able to ride that I can't even
give on that our star so our sisters
store here in Chandler is goddamn ready
for us it's amazing because I did talk
about the new Harley's on
episode and there was a very very big
loud noise made when these new bikes
were released if anybody watches sons of
anarchy you know all about the bikes
they ride is called the Dyna the
predecessor to that it was my favorite
bike of all time the Harley FX are the
one I got ran over on I missed that bike
to this day and I don't miss a lot of
things when I sell them I'm done with
them you know like I'm done with that
but that bike I definitely miss so they
discontinued the Dyna and a lot of big
noise because people are like Oh
sacrilege and they come out with this
bike called the Fat Bob which they
always had in a Dinah form but now it's
a single shock kind of monoshock vibe
with a whole new frame and everybody's
saying this bike handles like no other
when you buy a Dinah you got to put
about 10 grand into it to make what this
bike is and a lot of the old guard which
is also like goes down with my bits of
there's no good music anymore people do
not like change and they do not like
growth and this bike I'm dying to ride
it because everybody is loving it yeah
it's a lot like it - the craftsmanship
there if you relate it to music the UM
cover kind of changes but the quality's
still there and it's an improve you got
to write them to find out for yourself
yeah that's what we're about to do and
most people that I say always complain
about any kind of change like be it
sports and FL new rules or or art or
anything any kind of change most of the
people that make all the noise aren't
even buyers you know to me and they're
like out I can't believe it but
they haven't bought anything ever they
just like to complain you're just
comparing it to what you know and not
reaching out for more you know it's
crazy to me because everybody with
Harley wants the ultimate handling so
they put all this money into a diner
with shocks and
motor and handlebars and and Brembo
brakes and a different seat and
everything and now basically out of the
gate you've got all that for a cheap
price and and they're like nah them
you know the only my only my only
complaint would be forward controls
because I'm short and I'd like to ride
aggressive with the with the mid mid
controls
that's my only complaint but as I saw
how you guys fixed it up I was like
goddamn that bike looks badass it looks
road warrior right and they're only
gonna get better especially with the
aftermarket stuff that's coming out
usually it's about six months to a year
sometimes with the model change before
the aftermarket gets with it but there
are some tweaks they Harley is gonna
have to do but for the most parts the
changes for the better really is and
we're out here there's no hell not in
Arizona Arizona yet it's so funny man
like whenever I'm traveling around
America I saw a guy per and I were just
in Austin this is hilarious the
guys riding down the freeway with his
helmet on his arm like man not too huh
yeah but it wasn't that hot it was
almost like he's like I'll only wear
this if it gets cold or so so if he went
down they would have to pry the helmet
off his arm that he should have been
went off with it
I love that I used to do a bit and it
just reminded me I got to do it again
when people go yeah I stopped right and
when the helmet law came in that
and I was like that's that's like saying
you stopped when aids came
around for me it's full-face or nothing
man I love the full face once you ride
with a helmet you're like what an idiot
I am first of all the DB of the wind is
so loud it's like 120 DB that's
like being right in front of a speaker
at a concert and then when a rock or bug
hits you holy yeah yeah like shot
like a 22 you're right so I love that
that's there's always complainers my
entire life it would be like I don't
ride the helmet law they don't
tell
what to do all these people and they
like you know what I found when the
helmet law kicked in people didn't like
to ride anyway and it was their excuse
to get out and nowadays with the helmets
they vent actually better than not
wearing one and there's amazing carbon
fiber yeah we've got a good assortment
of apparel parts all that alcohol Harley
yeah
l cone Harley incredible been a great
sponsor for this podcast over a year and
a half I cannot people fly in come from
Texas come visit us we took the train in
yeah the podcast right we had guys a guy
flew in from Pat the plumber from Santa
Cruz bought a bike you know and that
like my pride I love that my sponsors
are that I love like in a perfect
world I would love just to have the
patreon page you donate to that and I
don't have to have any ads in a perfect
world this you know this is a grueling
as you if you watch this live you can
see I'm doing all kinds of I got to
think up the show I got a book the guest
I got to edit it I got to post it up I
got a I got to pay for Lipson equipment
everything so it's it's definitely a
labor of love but if I'm gonna have
sponsors it's gotta be something that I
love and Harley's and of course Rolex I
got you know a Rolex sponsor and now I
got a new sponsor coming pretty soon
I'll talk about that's awesome and so
it's great that and and then you and I
have been friends through it all which
is incredible you know we've seen some
great shows I was just thinking the last
petty show was mojo right down the
street one of them had seen and yet ZZ
Top was going to open up but he had
Chuck Berry coming instead right crazy
yeah yeah opens up for Chuck Berry
you and I saw we saw a GNR together in
Vegas that's when I had died and that's
when I got the diabetes yeah
then we saw we saw
a CDC at Dodger Stadium we've seen some
great shows together and we've we've had
a great friendship now we're out here at
the all things comedy and you're a big
comedy fan that's what's amazing cuz my
sponsor Elco gnarly is they're all
comedy fans and rock and roll fans it's
just a perfect fit has been weed
something out of the box for us rather
than just pitching radio ads and whatnot
so it's working out well yeah right
because radio ads is just kind of burnt
they go away in a couple days these are
all gonna be on these back and listen to
these which I do myself and yeah alright
man well let's go ride these cars and
then we'll talk about them later on on
another episode and thank you everybody
the tuned and thanks guys it came by we
had a rockin four people here it was
really about four or five this
this is getting huge five people I
mean you cannot beat five people right
[Laughter]
once again I want to thank Bill burr and
now magical for having me on the network
years ago it was a highlight and and I
constantly constantly grind to put out
great episodes and I do it mostly
because I don't want to let them down or
at all the listeners so please subscribe
and leave reviews on iTunes and spread
the word and don't forget tweet this
week your favorite episode on Twitter
whatever it is just put the link and
tweet it up and we'll start we'll start
retweet and then spread in all the word
I don't care what episode it is in the
last three hundred and eighty seven
episodes five and a half years of doing
this show find your favorite post it up
and and tell me why thanks for tuning in
everybody candles lit